which is a traditional seafood dish
a lot of times it's made with tuna but
instead of making it with tuna today
we're gonna make it with salmon so fresh
salmon that we've cubed
so you have a skillet drew with some
olive oil
i do and it seems like it's a really
good temperature right now and also
kim julie and precious are incredible
vff's
who have joined us for cookbook today
they all made this dish
uh ahead of time and they might have
some questions to pop
in here in their tiago if that's okay oh
i love it
yes yes yes yes yeah i do have a
question
about the fish sure uh i'm severely
allergic to like shellfish and i noticed
this recipe was done with salmon but i
wondered if any other proteins
would be could be substituted as well
good question
oh great question yeah yeah you can use
chicken if you don't want to use any
kind of seafood
um it really works with any protein it's
kind of up to you
do you um you ready to throw the pasta
in this is a pretty quick
i am ready ready giada i'm so
ready and i've got my pasta right here
did you salt your water
no and i now know i also learned
um you know how what a cardinal no-no
it is to put olive oil in the pasta
no olive oil in the pasta you're ruining
it
so once the um once you get the salmon
kind of cooking
you can add the red onion and the garlic
i have a question sure if i did not have
red onion could i
substitute a shallot or something else
good question absolutely
you can definitely use shallots you can
use a regular brown onion
a white onion really any of it it's just
to give it a little extra flair yeah it
smells really good and it's a really
quick dinner
so once you've added the onion and the
garlic you guys ready to add tomatoes
yep
so i've got some cherry tomatoes that i
just have
so we're going to create like this
really light sort of i think amalfi
coast
think um really light tomato sauce
like from fresh tomatoes so now the
tomatoes are breaking down hopefully for
everybody are they
yep absolutely they're looking really
really really good
are you ready to add a little bit of
wine we're not going to add a lot of
wine just a little hint
to give it extra flavor and that's the
great thing about these recipes is not
that i've
taken everything out of it i've just
reduced the amounts a little bit so you
get
the enhancement of that flavor from the
wine
there we go it adds a little acidity to
the tomatoes which creates
a really well-balanced sauce in the end
so a little bit of white wine
john i have a question as you're
stirring your pasta i noticed that
you've suggested that gluten-free pasta
could be used
as well but what about a plant-based
pasta like a chickpea pasta
good question sure if you like chickpea
pasta that'd be great
lentil pasta is really great um
there's um edamame pastas now that work
really well as well
okay thank you you guys ready to add
some olives i just added my olives but
we're also going to add the parsley the
chopped parsley and the oregano
so again reinforcing yeah sure
so i'm not big on olives i didn't add
that many so does that compromise the
flavor of the dish at all
no you you can reduce the olives if you
don't like the olives it's just this
is a traditional dish that has that
flavor component of the rich olives that
salty rich olive
with the light vibrant flavor of tomato
but you could use capers or use less
yeah yeah thank you yeah yeah i don't
want to forget about my pasta here
did you taste your pasta
almost i missed my mac i missed my mouth
on that one
be careful now giada my pasta is ready
can i add it straight into the bowl or
do i want to drain it yup
no i just i take this nifty little pasta
scooper
this colander looks like spoon and i add
it right into the pan
the whole idea here is that you save the
pasta water real hot
so you don't drain it you throw the
pasta right into the skillet
um so that way it can start to absorb
finish cooking
in the sauce and absorb the flavor of
the sauce
and we're going to add a little bit of
pasta water
and the pasta water amount depends yeah
go ahead so i wasn't sure of the
consistency that the pasta sauce should
be so how much pasta water
should be used well i would say that you
can use anywhere from
a couple tablespoons to a half a cup so
it kind of depends but you want
you want it to be saucy so i just used
two ladle fulls
so that's gonna be well i used one
little bowl so that's gonna be about a
quarter cup so i might use one more
so up to half a cup yeah i wouldn't use
more than a half a cup you shouldn't
need to
and then i finished it with a little bit
of parmesan cheese
parmigiano that's wonderful
and allow the cheese to slowly get mixed
in
and just take it easy and just kind of
fold it all together
and as you can see it should smell
really good
does it smell good it smells so
good it's insane it's very sweet you
guys
this was so fun does it taste good my
gosh
oh my gosh it's so good
it's delicious you guys now kim and
kim what was um one of your favorite
things about making this dish
that it was quick it was easy and it was
one pot just except for you know
boiling the pasta pasta that's exactly
what dirty up a whole lot of dishes yeah
that's and that makes a huge difference
um julie what about you
it was perfect i work full time i'm busy
it was perfect for a weeknight meal
it also has such a clean beautiful light
taste about it precious what was your
favorite part
yeah i wouldn't say the taste the fresh
the freshness of the dish because
coming out of winter i was eating so
many heavy things
that this was just perfect for a spring
evening
and i love that it's so fresh and
delicious and light
i'm struggling
[Applause]
that makes me happy i can't stop hold on
it's really fabulous
i'm so happy that makes me that makes my
day
i cannot thank you enough
you're just so amazing giada i'm so
excited and thrilled
that we could do cookbook club with you
it is so me
me too thank you for picking me oh thank
you for doing it and kim and julian
precious it is so wonderful to go on
this journey with you and don't forget
to get
your copy of chiata's new book
it's drop-in it's available right now
get it while it's hot
and then if you want to make this recipe
for the delicious putanesca
at home and you can send it to our
website go to thedrewbraymoreshow.com
and don't forget
to don't forget to join our cookbook
chit chat say that five times fast
on social media using the hashtag drew's
cookbook club what an honor oh thank you
tiana thank you so much
thanks ladies
[Music]